boris johnson there with harry his wife
uh he has made the speech he's
said farewell uh to his uh parliamentary
and political back as you can see ben
wallace big applause and cheers and he's
got into the car
and that is it there you can see them uh
the children not there their small
toddler and baby romy yes less than a
year old uh and that's it the end of the
boris johnson regime regime he and
carrie johnson in the car to see the
queen fulsome applause
in the street in downing street from his
uh parliamentary his political
supporters his allies his sister rachel
johnson nadine
there's sadness here uh there's uh hugs
uh and that's it boris johnson is
leaving downing street uh for the final
time as prime minister we'll come onto
what you said in a moment but just
reflection it's a remarkably human
moment isn't it looking around you saw
some faces that were really
really upset and hurt by by what they
were facing sadness yeah genuine sadness
and actually i i i mean
jacob rees-mogg i could see him out in
the distance he looked upset i mean a
lot of people here upset boris johnson
did command fierce loyalty from those
who supported him and you saw that in
the way that they defended him some of
his cabinet
to the very end but it is over and what
it was a i i would say a a classic boris
johnson speech there uh there was a
serious message injected uh with humor
at the end where he talked about if you
can unite dylan the dog and uh larry the
cat the two uh pets actually larry's
just um emerged from downing street
there
then you can unite the conservative
parties he called for colleagues uh to
come together as i thought he went
through his greatest hits you heard that
he talked about the vaccine rollout he
talked about the war in ukraine and
britain's role in leading
the world in its responses he talked
about you know he got applause uh for
some of that but also
you could
sense the bitterness
in the beginning of that speech done in
a very johnson way uh but when he talked
about it was a relay race you said and
the rules halfway through changed and
that we raised our eyebrows with that we
did because it was almost
it's a reflection of i won a confidence
vote you remember there was a confidence
vote which he won
and still uh the party wanted him out uh
and then that precipitated the
resignations and the threat of a second
confidence vote and he to the very end
thought he could fight on and it was
only when his closest political islam
said you'll either
get forced out by cabinet and colleagues
or you will face another confidence vote
and get forced out that he knew the game
was our but a little swipe there really
at a parliamentary party that forced him
out of office when he certainly didn't
want to go
what did he say about the energy crisis
because that is what the country really
care about the moment he said that the
government will give people the cash
they need to get through the energy
crisis
and he said uh if putin thinks he can
succeed uh he against the british people
they are utterly deluded echo in that
sense that he gave last week about
urging the public uh to stick with it uh
that the price worth paying is worth it
for the freedom of ukraine but of course
when people are facing such crippling
energy drills worried about their own
livelihoods and their own families uh
expecting action on that um
what did he say about party unity he
said it's time for politics to be over
and he said it's time to get behind liz
trust and her program and deliver for
the country and the issue about the
programme is actually the difference in
economic approach of the sunat camp
versus the trust camp it's going to be a
big issue over the autumn as she does
record levels of borrowing potentially
in order to fund fast uh energy price
freezes in some form potentially and
then those promised tax cuts and what
does it do to the markets you've seen
the pound devaluing now at near three
decade lows as investors get nervous
about the economic credibility of the uk
she has a hell of a job on her hands
both to reassure the public and
investors in these first few days we
expect the energy packet by package
potentially thursday by the end of the
week yeah and better as you say it seems
classically johnson in his speech some
laughs for some people and a serious
message as well but i think it's worth
reflecting is the street starts to clear
because you know boris johnson and his
wife carrie have now left on their way
to see the queen at balmoral
reflecting on his legacy reflecting on
the country that he will leave after
three years three and a half years in
office
boris johnson has been one of the
shortest serving prime ministers in
modern history which given that he won
as he said himself the biggest electoral
majority since the days of margaret
thatcher
uh you expected him to have a long run
at the premiership we expected i
remember talking about it on the night
he won that election that he had won the
power to reshape this country with a
majority uh that david cameron nor
theresa may never enjoyed when they were
prime ministers he had it within his
power to really change
the country and in in the end as i said
you know at the time
in the end it was his own mistakes
missteps that brought himself down that
brought an end
to his reign but he is a consequential
prime minister
it might have been a short tenure ship
but it was so impactful in terms of
brexit he delivered one of the biggest
economic and political changes to this
country this century the ramifications
of which will last for decades to come
he then had to handle a pandemic and
deliver the vaccine rollout he then was
hospitalized himself
nearly put into
intensive care potentially he managed to
stay off a ventilator but he was very
ill bravely ill at that time
and i think when history looks back on
him uh the fact that he was the man that
campaigned for brexit and then delivered
it it makes him a consequential prime
minister despite all the flaws that
eventually drove him out of office